merry christmas happy holidays and
freaky festivists to you all from your
good friends at scp explained deck the
halls with vows of
scp-407-induced plant life because today
we're going to hit you with the kind of
christmas cheer you just can't contain
hang your stockings pour a tall glass of
eggnog and slip on your most hideous
yuletide sweater because this is a
ketter kind of christmas we've discussed
christmas anomalies both in depth and in
passing on this channel before like
scp-4666 the positively terrifying yule
man
whose ritual christmas time slaying
strike fear into the hearts of families
everywhere or scp-784
christmas cheer a community where it's
christmas every day
and anyone who refuses to show the
proper spirit is dragged off and given a
forcible re-education in the reason for
the season there's even the pitiful
scp-1933
a fat sweaty and perpetually drunk
middle-aged man in a santa suit who has
irish cream for blood reminds me of my
uncle frank but today we're dealing with
something really special a christmas
variety show hosted by everyone's
favorite anomalous foundation researcher
scp-963
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry we
mean dr bright dr bright is getting
ready to receive guests for his
christmas party like no other and the
good news is we're all invited there's
going to be stories songs comedy and
more cameos than you could shake a yule
log at so get comfortable it's gonna be
a fun one but first a quick message from
this episode sponsors the fine folks at
the shark punching center the first and
last line of defense between us and
those dark-eyed sub-aquatic menaces and
of course the latest kegeltastic product
from our good pals of the doctor
wondertainment toy company a perfect
stocking filler for the christmas season
that's right we're talking about spider
party just add water for 80 000 legs
worth of arachno arachnofundia
warning parental supervision required
your definition of arachnophonbia may
differ from that used by dr
wondertainment avoid use of this product
if you are sensitive to spider venom not
for use in households with pencil which
are situated on reclaimed toxic waste
stumps and or indian burial grounds dr
wondertainment is not responsible for
any cases of spideritis spiderosis or
spidermania caused by use of this
product not to be used for gambling
purposes without the express written
consent of doctor entertainment oh and
of course an additional thank you to our
friends at the mana charitable
foundation for their generous grant more
on that one later while dr bright
prepared for guests
scp-1845 a collection of freakishly
intelligent animals including a raccoon
a crow a baby pig a chicken and a fox by
the name of king eugenio prepared a
dress rehearsal for a nativity scene
conflict erupted when the chicken kept
flubbing her lines and the other cast
members found it strange that king
eugenio insisted on playing the baby
jesus himself by all accounts he was
kind of a nightmare to work with thanks
to his massive ego the situation
worsened when scp-329-j
a floating yield sign that believes it's
a ghost turned up claiming to be the
ghost of christmas past and started
bothering king eugenio if you think this
is weird you're going to have real
trouble with the rest of this so we
recommend sitting back putting your feet
up and just rolling with it because it's
only going to get stranger from here
anyway back to the living room of dr
jack bright who was singing a special
scp foundation parody of the christmas
carol god rest ye merry gentlemen when
the first set of guests arrive it was dr
charles ogden gears a famously humorless
foundation senior researcher dressed in
his own adorably gaudy christmas attire
but he wasn't alone he'd brought special
musical guests captain and tenniel the
classic 1970s duo responsible for hits
such as love will keep us together and
muskrat love they'd actually attended
gigs like this before but thanks to the
beauty of class a amnestics it was all
new to them let's ignore the murky
ethical implications of that and keep on
trucking next this christmas
extravaganza careened into another
anomalous skit this one featuring
scp-1192
a little boy named timmy who was somehow
transformed into a bird and count rocula
a badass heavy metal aficionado summoned
by scp-1987-j's
anomalously sick chord progression timmy
was naturally a little upset about being
trapped as a bird and thus he was unable
to spend christmas with his family count
rocula being the lord of ultimate
rockness refused to let the poor bird
boy suffer in order to cheer him up he
grabbed his guitar and launched into a
spirited rock and roll christmas carol
with much racier lyrics than you'd
probably expect from a wholesome
christmas tune the count was left
feeling a little nervous afterwards when
timmy started asking him what a
cameltoe was the sooner we get away from
this little disaster of a segment the
better back to dr bright's living room
once more the good anomalous doctor had
just finished telling a hilarious
anecdote to dr gears and 1970s music
powerhouse captain centennial when dr
gears took the opportunity to break some
bad news a certain very rowdy former
party guest had found out about this
year's meetup and he would likely be
joining any minute now much too bright's
dismay as if on cue the door burst open
and there stood scp-076-2
also known as abel the immortal
swordsman wearing an ugly christmas
sweater and a santa hat yelling did
somebody say party
dr bright was mortified at last year's
party abel had gotten tanked on hard
eggnog and embarrassed them all in front
of country music legend willie nelson
with his antics specifically he'd stolen
a local sleigh and used it to run over
bright's grandmother hilarious however
abel insisted that this time around he'd
be well behaved only time would tell if
that prediction held any water he began
to sing a personalized parody of away in
a manger in a grading falsetto voice as
an act of penance let's get away from
those goofballs again and hop over to
another ace comedic duo lord blackwood
and wellington g wonder horse blackwood
also known as scp-1867
is a telepathic sea slug who believes he
was once a galvanting british noble and
explorer and wellington also known as
scp-1156
is a talking horse with a thick cockney
accent and a dapper woolen scarf and top
hat this pair of talking creatures
wished the audience a very merry
christmas before engaging in
conversation however this didn't get
very far as lord blackwood couldn't
understand wellington's thick cockney
accent when lord blackwood got too
frustrated to go on he called wellington
a horse's ass everybody laughs roll on
snare drums curtains
now then back to dr bright's
increasingly chaotic christmas house
party abel was already getting a little
sloshed and telling wild jokes when
another guest appeared at the door when
dr bright answered he saw dr rights a
female fellow researcher standing there
in a full body trench coat she expressed
a desire to meet dr bright under the
mistletoe to which she replied right i i
didn't put up any mistletoe this year
but right obviously in the christmas
spirit with a smile on her face and with
no concern for the lack of mistletoe at
the party disrobe from her trench coat
donned in her hand-knitted wool
christmas two-piece she began to dance
towards dr bright while singing a parody
of the saucy christmas hit santa
baby
okay um
let's cut to another word from one of
our sponsors the wonderful folks at the
mana charitable foundation the world's
leading anomalous charity group in this
sponsorship break mana charitable
foundation representative sally
struthers placed a small mechanical
contraption on the table and said this
is the christmas miracle maker thanks to
state-of-the-art terraforming technology
this durable and easy to use device once
activated will induce rapid and
aggressive climate change in order to
transform its surrounding environment
into a perfect snowy winter's day just
in time for a white christmas the seed
banks and genetic samples contained
within it will ensure that majestic
evergreens just right for decorating and
reindeer perfect for pulling a one horse
open sleigh will replace all the local
flora and fauna and it can even whip up
a christmas dinner with all the
trimmings for those souls in need every
one of your donations puts us one step
closer to our goal of manufacturing and
air dropping 15 000 of these units
across africa in time for christmas eve
so please call in your pledge or write a
check today and let them know it's
christmas time again thank you sally
let's get back to dr bright's party now
things are looking a little more safe
for work if only slightly at least
decorated russian mobile task force
operative agent strelnikov had joined
the party and was naturally beginning to
make multiple jokes about how much he
hates chechens much to the discomfort of
everyone else in attendance the other
party guest tried to make him discuss
literally anything else but he refused
repeatedly circling back to telling
stories about chechens he only broke
from his diatribe to give a rendition of
the formerly popular trololo meme song
which he insisted was a traditional
russian song of homecoming back to king
eugenio the fox who'd been going through
a parallel christmas carol narrative
this whole time during dr bride's story
the talking yield sign was a spirit of
christmas past and while we sadly missed
his spirit of christmas present as we
join him before his own gravestone we
can see that his spirit of christmas yet
to come was
scp-173 the sculpture as the sculpture
pointed towards king eugenia's grave in
judgmental silence eugenio came to terms
with what a jerk he'd been when he was
freed from this horrible fantasy he
realized that he needed to change his
ways and thankfully there was still time
back to dr bright's christmas party
which was in full swing however captain
antennial who had been in charge of
cooking the christmas goose had made a
terrible mistake they were told to run
it through scp-914
on the fine setting which would create a
wonderful goose roast but instead they
ran it through the very fine mode
turning it into a collection of live
goslings however in their greatest hour
of need a hero rose dr cleff appeared at
the door dressed as santa claus with
enough delicious clam chowder for
everyone and as the party guests enjoyed
their chowder even more guests arrived
king eugenio wellington scp-173
lord blackwood the ghostly yield sign
count rocula timmy the bird and even
sally strothers while the rest of the
anomalous animals formed a perfect
nativity scene while count rocula
performed a rock and roll rendition of
come all ye faithful dr bright was
content that everyone here had learned
the true meaning of christmas after all
even king eugenio had learned a lot
about being more kind and compassionate
to his fellow beasts with the help of
lord blackwood he obtained scp-660
the butler's handbell and used it to
summon mr deeds along with a delicious
fully cooked christmas goose with all
the trimmings while dr rice flirted with
abel and the other party guests prepared
to enjoy their chowder and goose dr
bright wished everyone a happy christmas
with timmy adding and 343 bless us
everyone we help this little exploration
into how the foundation celebrates
christmas has helped your heart grow
three sizes this day
and not in the way it would if you ate a
meal off of scp-807
stay tuned for a ketter kind of hanukkah
and a ketter kind of kwanzaa coming soon
now go check out
scp-4666 the yule man and alaska
doomsday weapon scp-804
world without man for more snow-swept
havoc from the scp foundation